[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
queridos amigos amigas presta mucha
atención porque lo que aquí os vamos a
contar no os va a dejar indiferentes y
para empezar quedaros con este dato dos
terceras partes de todos los habitantes
del planeta tierra viven en países donde
la tasa de fertilidad no alcanza ni
siquiera la tasa de reemplazo esto es
2,1 nacimientos por mujer en edad fértil
que se considera es la tasa que permite
mantener una población estable en el
largo plazo de hecho en el mundo
desarrollado tan solo israel ha logrado
situarse constantemente por encima de
esta cifra y evidentemente esto es algo
que tiene consecuencias fijaos en el
crecimiento de la población mundial
alcanza la tasa más baja desde 1950 de
hecho el aumento de la mortalidad la
caída en el número de nacimientos y una
menor inmigración neta por culpa de la
pandemia hijo que durante los años 2020
y 2021 la población europea se redujera
en más de 2 millones de personas
[Música]
este es un proceso al que nos podemos ir
acostumbrando porque será recurrente a
lo largo del presente siglo en europa y
también en otros muchos países la
población de japón se ha estado
reduciendo desde el año 2010 la de corea
del sur comenzó a contraerse en 2020 y
se espera que la población china haga lo
propio como muy tarde este mismo año o
el siguiente aunque hay expertos que
incluso apuntan que este declive ya ha
comenzado de hecho se espera que para
mediados del siglo la población china se
reduzca en 12 millones de personas por
año
qué queréis que os diga buena parte del
mundo cada vez tiene menos jóvenes y
muchas más personas mayores ahora viene
estará un momento porque esta no es toda
la historia
quizás no seamos en el día a día
conscientes de ello pero áfrica el
continente siempre olvidado está
experimentando lo que algunos consideran
como el mayor despegue demográfico de
toda la historia de la humanidad un
crecimiento que lejos de ralentizarse se
ha disparado durante las últimas décadas
y que promete marcar un antes y un
después en la mismísima historia de la
humanidad este es el siglo de áfrica
cyril ramaphosa presidente de sudáfrica
y ojo que esto no ha hecho más que
empezar el cambio que os vamos a contar
va mucho más allá de lo que seguro
seguro nunca os habéis planteado
arranquemos
[Música]
pero antes dejadme que os cuente una
cosa que creo que os va a interesar a
todos se habla mucho de crisis y la
palabra recesión está por todas partes
ahora bien podemos detectar una crisis
financiera o económica antes de que ésta
ocurra existe algún tipo de día que
podamos seguir para saber cuando estamos
cerca de experimentar un nuevo
cataclismo financiero pues sabéis que lo
cierto es que en cierta forma sé que
existe tras la gran crisis financiera
del 2008 dos economistas de la
universidad de berkeley desarrollaron un
método para poder diagnosticar crisis
financieras un método al alcance de
todos quieres saber más sobre esta
cuestión quieres saber cómo podemos
diagnosticar una crisis financiera antes
incluso de que ocurra pues no te pierdas
el último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido
el canal información de financiera de
activos con el que participamos os dejo
el enlace en la descripción pero dicho
esto continuemos
[Música]
como áfrica cambiará el mundo
en 2018 el presidente museveni de uganda
abrió su discurso sobre el estado del
país presumiendo de que la población de
uganda había saltado de unos 14 millones
de personas en 1986 a más de 40 millones
el crecimiento demográfico anual que
había sido de un 25 por ciento de media
en los 20 años anteriores a su
larguísimo reinado como presidente había
superado el 35 por ciento y esto esto ha
hecho que wanda tenga una de las
poblaciones más jóvenes de todo el
planeta su edad media es de apenas 17
años y para que os hagáis una idea tres
cuartas partes de los ugandeses tienen
menos de 30 años una enorme cantera
preparada para tener muchos muchísimos
hijos porque amigos amigas hablamos de
un país donde las mujeres tienen de
media 5 hijos esto está siguiendo otras
cosas porque la población es muy joven y
además se empiezan a tener hijos muy
pronto algo que por cierto no ha
cambiado a pesar de que las tasas de
mortalidad infantil se han desplomado el
resultado la población de uganda está
creciendo a un ritmo de casi el 40 por
ciento por década
y eso no es todo en otro discurso
televisado el propio presidente museveni
fue muy claro áfrica ha estado sufriendo
de su población ahora lo estamos
solucionando yoweri museveni presidente
de uganda y es que veréis a pesar de ser
el segundo continente más grande de todo
el mundo áfrica sólo ha sido responsable
de una quinta parte del crecimiento
demográfico mundial desde 1950 pero
ahora ahora eso está cambiando por
completo la cultura la religión e
incluso la política todo absolutamente
todo es pro natalista en áfrica y amigos
amigas podéis creerme eso digo que se
han puesto las pilas y vaya si lo han
hecho una vez que te das cuenta de su
escala bueno digamos que es probable que
te estalle la cabeza el mundo que
conoces va a cambiar por completo
durante las próximas décadas fijaos
en 1914 se estima que la población de
áfrica era de apenas 124 millones de
personas hoy son ya más de 1.340
millones de africanos mientras la
población de la ssa se multiplicó entre
3 y 4 veces la población africana se
multiplicó por 11 y eso son palabras
mayores por ejemplo durante la
revolución industrial la población de
europa apenas se duplicó hablamos por
tanto de un crecimiento inédito en toda
la historia de la humanidad pero eso eso
han sido tan solo el comienzo las
estimaciones de naciones unidas apuntan
que para el año 2050 la población de
áfrica superará los 2400 millones de
personas es decir que si en 1980 una de
cada 10 personas del mundo eran
africanas a mediados de este mismo siglo
en apenas unos pocos años
aproximadamente una de cada cuatro
personas en la tierra será de este
continente
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
esto supone 2500 millones de personas
equivale a toda la población que tenía
el mundo en 1950 pues bien apenas 100
años más tarde esas era tan solo la
población de áfrica y de hecho ahora
mismo este continente de ya con mucha
diferencia el principal motor del
crecimiento demográfico del mundo por
ejemplo actualmente sólo 8 países tienen
un crecimiento de su población superior
al 3% lo que implica que los habitantes
se dupliquen cada 20 o 24 años pues bien
todos están en áfrica actualmente sólo
11 países tienen una tasa de fertilidad
de 5 o más hijos todos están en áfrica
de los 20 países de todo el mundo cuya
población crecerá más para el año 2050
12 estarán precisamente en esta región
del mundo en otras palabras acostúmbrate
pero el mundo que conoces dependerá cada
vez más y más de esta tierra
[Música]
y eso eso no es todo lo más increíble es
que todo apunta a que la población
africana seguirá creciendo más y más de
hecho para mediados de siglo será la
única con tasas de crecimiento relevante
de todo el planeta tierra en 2050
aproximadamente el 40 por ciento de
todos los nacimientos tendrán lugar
sabéis dónde exacto en 2050 38 de los 40
países con la edad media más reducida
del mundo estarán ya sabéis donde así
que para finales de siglo pues muchos
expertos incluyendo naciones unidas
apuntan a que la población de áfrica
supondrá cerca del 40 por ciento de toda
la población mundial 4 de cada 10
habitantes yo juego porque si se cumple
este pronóstico eso querría decir que
áfrica será responsable ni más ni menos
que de más del 90 por ciento del
crecimiento de la población mundial
entre los años 2020 y 2100 os imagináis
un mundo donde la mitad de todos los
jóvenes o casi la mitad de toda la
fuerza laboral sea precisamente africana
evidentemente eso cambiaría por completo
la realidad global el continente ya está
ahora olvidado se convertiría en algo
así como el motor del planeta una
sociedad joven y pujante frente a las
envejecidas sociedades de los países
desarrollados eso lo cambiaría todo y si
vale haber hablar en el 2100 pues
evidentemente no es co hablar el año
2050 a un plazo tan largo las
previsiones pueden no cumplirse pero
amigos amigas si algo parece claro
meridiano es que como poco uno de cada
tres habitantes de toda la tierra será
de este continente
[Música]
fijaos por ejemplo en el caso de níger
uno de los países más pobres del mundo y
uno de los aliados por cierto de
occidente en la lucha contra la
infiltración yihadista en el sahel en
este país las mujeres tienen una media
de más de siete hijos la cual por cierto
se ha incrementado en los últimos años
eso explica que la edad media del país
sea de apenas 15 años vamos que
prácticamente hablamos de un macro
colegio en apenas 100 años entre 1950 y
2050 este país habrá visto multiplicarse
su población por 25 de 25 millones a más
de 60 millones de habitantes
ahora bien la primera pregunta que
seguro seguro a muchos os ha venido a la
cabeza espero realmente coge tanta gente
en áfrica
pues lo cierto es que sí a pesar de que
su población se ha multiplicado por seis
desde 1950 áfrica sigue siendo
esencialmente un continente vacío su
densidad de población es de unas 44
personas por kilómetro cuadrado y por
ejemplo si dejamos de lado a los
pequeños estados insulares sólo 5 países
ruanda burundi y uganda nigeria malawi
tienen densidades de población cercanas
o superiores a las 200 personas por
kilómetro cuadrado y para que os hagáis
una idea por ejemplo corea del sur
supera las quinientas y bangladesh las
1200 así que margen lo que se dice
margen pues hay de sobra ahora bien
realmente son fiables estas previsiones
es que en este continente no está
haciendo lugar lo que se conoce como
transición demográfica o es que los
expertos no lo han tenido en cuenta y
quizás la pregunta más importante de
todas que supondrá exactamente todo este
brutal crecimiento esta brutal
revolución demográfica para el resto del
mundo pues bien veámoslo
la anomalía del continente olvidado
y europa américa latina' cada vez que
una sociedad se ha modernizado y se ha
desarrollado económicamente ha tenido
lugar lo que conocemos como transición
demográfica en un primer momento la tasa
de mortalidad disminuye el crecimiento
de la población se acelera pero de
repente la fertilidad se desploma y el
crecimiento demográfico se ralentiza
hasta que prácticamente se frena del
todo e incluso comienza a ser negativo
por el creciente envejecimiento de la
población pues bien esa es la teoría y
la experiencia hasta el día de hoy pero
lo cierto es que en áfrica las cosas
parecen completamente distintas
aunque la tasa de mortalidad se ha
desplomado con fuerza y la esperanza de
vida de la población ha crecido mucho en
áfrica la reducción de las tasas de
fecundidad que están descendiendo a un
ritmo anormalmente reducido por ejemplo
en el áfrica sub-sahariana apenas ha
pasado de 65 nacimientos por mujer a 54
los últimos 20 años e incluso en algunos
países este indicador ha vuelto a crecer
de locos en algunos países de áfrica la
fecundidad aún no ha empezado a
descender y puede que esto no cambien
los próximos años en muchos otros los
cambios han sido limitados y vacilantes
mientras que algunos países que sí
estaban muy avanzados en sus
transiciones de fecundidad han seguido
caminos inesperados con transiciones de
fecundidad más lentas u estancadas bruno
show maker demógrafo experto en áfrica
ahí tenemos por ejemplo el caso de
egipto un país que parecía estar
completando la transición demográfica
pero cuya tasa de fertilidad ha pasado
de tres hijos en 2008 a 3,2 actualmente
un cambio en la tendencia que ha hecho
que la onu incremente su población
esperada para el año 2050 hasta los 160
millones de habitantes y de hecho aunque
tanto en el norte como en el sur de
áfrica la transición demográfica está
relativamente muy avanzada lo cierto es
que sus tasas de fertilidad se mantienen
muy por encima del resto del mundo
prácticamente en niveles de madre hijos
por mujer pero en cualquier caso espera
un momento porque lo que está ocurriendo
en la franja central del continente eso
eso es una auténtica explosión ahora
bien qué demonios pasa en áfrica
[Música]
pues lo cierto es que no está claro lo
que se sabe es que la cultura los
gobiernos y la religión son más por
natalidad que en cualquier otra parte
del mundo sabemos por ejemplo que las
encuestas nos dicen que en general las
familias africanas quieren tener muchos
hijos que en general empiezan a tenerlos
muy pronto y que utilizan pocos
anticonceptivos por ejemplo en níger las
mujeres sueñan con tener de 9 a 10 hijos
y los hombres ni más ni menos que 13
luego en los 11 países con más
crecimiento demográfico del continente
el primer nacimiento se suele tener en
la adolescencia y en angola a pesar de
que la mayoría de la población vive en
zonas urbanas y que tiene un pib per
cápita relativamente alto la tasa de
fecundidad sigue siendo de 6 hijos pero
vale ahora que sabemos todo esto la
pregunta es y que va a suponer
exactamente este cambio pues atentos
[Música]
el nuevo amanecer
hola amigos amigas el mundo está
cambiando tan rápido que es posible que
no seamos capaces de apreciarlo en su
plenitud por ejemplo sabíais que en 2020
por primera vez desde el siglo 19 las
economías de asia superaron en tamaño a
todas las del resto del mundo juntas
pues tal cual como lo escucháis y luego
los países más ricos y particularmente
los de la vieja europa no sólo se
enfrentan al estancamiento demográfico
sino que además tienen poblaciones cada
vez más y más envejecidas por ejemplo se
espera que para el año 2060 la población
de la unión europea apenas supere el 5
por ciento de la población mundial y eso
no es todo es que además el 30 por
ciento de toda la población europea
tendrá más de 65 años en otras palabras
que el mundo será cada vez mucho más
asiático y sobre todo mucho pero que
mucho más africano piensan un continente
que tendrá la misma población kim gay
china juntarse en 2050 piensa en un
continente con una clase media creciente
una rápida urbanización y que tendrá la
población más joven del planeta en 2050
piensa en áfrica aquí muy mía vecina
presidente del banco africano de
desarrollo y desde luego si algo nos
dice la historia es que las poblaciones
jóvenes y crecientes han solido
traducirse antes o después en un
creciente peso económico y político
claro que esto también supone enormes
retos actualmente cada año 30 de áfrica
nos alcanzan los 15 años una edad que en
esta región se considera como el acceso
a la vida laboral por eso durante los
próximos años y las próximas décadas
áfrica necesitará generar enormes
cantidades de empleo
pero eso no es todo además aunque el
continente sea capaz de crecer es
evidente que su influencia en el resto
del mundo y el peso de la inmigración va
a crecer con fuerza probablemente sobre
todo en la vieja europa al fin y al cabo
es un continente próximo que tendrá
muchos empleos disponibles como
consecuencia del envejecimiento
demográfico así que amigos amigas es muy
posible que para mediados de este siglo
áfrica comienza a tener un peso mucho
más destacado en la agenda política
económica y comunicativa del mundo
la pregunta es estamos preparados será
una adaptación sencilla qué
consecuencias puede tener para el resto
del mundo la emergencia de áfrica deben
acaso los países más ricos intentar
promover una cultura más abierta y
moderna en este continente hablo por
ejemplo de la integración de la mujer el
reconocimiento de la libertad sexual o
la integración de minorías de todo tipo
pues queridos amigos amigas estas son
las grandes preguntas que están por
resolver así que de momento si os parece
os invitamos a dejarnos vuestras
opiniones en los comentarios y por
supuesto si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle a like y
suscribiros abisal político un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]